なんで野球したいの？
野球したいわけじゃない
こんにちは！　はじめしゃちょーと
まさき取締役です
コンタクトレンズをつけようと思います
ンフッ//
目悪いわけじゃないんですけどちょっと悪くて
メガネは今まで2個あったんですけど全部失くしちゃって
フッ//
かと言ってコンタクトつけるのも怖いんで今までつけなかったんですけれど
つけてみようかと思いまして
今回はコンタクトを付けて見る動画です
つけたことある？
ない
目悪い？
目が悪いけどメガネだから・・・
今は？
今は裸眼
というわけで今日はコンタクトレンズを付ける練習をしたいと思います
普通のやつをつけても微妙なのでカラコンを買いました。
Perfect・Series １０枚入り☆
１０枚も入ってんの？
えっ・・・わかんない
あ、ごめん
全然違ったわ
ワンデイって書いてあった
フハハハハwww
ちょっと怖くない？
怖い。普通にやばい。だって目の中に異物入れるんでしょ？
そうだよ
アカンでしょ普通に
で、色がね
アカンでしょ
掛けてた、今??
掛けてないわ
色がねマイコレッドです
うわぁ―――
やばい
うわぁエグイ
怖い怖い怖い
怖いこれwwwwwwwww
ほんと怖いよぉ
コンタクトつけてる人
いるっしょ結構
あの人たちは
どういう
神経で
入れてるのかっていうのを
おいら知りたかったんだよ
うわーコンタクトこんな付け方
すんだよ
うわー無理無理無理
はい、僕の普通の目はこんな感じでーす
これ
全部左手
に出すんだって
えっ????
つまんで　で、ピッてやって
からこうやって
こうやって
とるってこと
えーもーもー無理無理―
左手の中指で
上のまぶたを引き上げ　中指!?
右手の中指で、下のまぶたを引き下げます
そそそう　でここに今
こっちに乗ってるんで　なるほどなるほど　えっ?
人差し指でつけるってこと?　うん
でこう入れて
あーーー
あーーーーーーーーーw
これだって目ん玉の裏側とか行ったら手術でしょ
行かないって
絶対俺今日終わったら救急の準備
出すよ、じゃあ　押し去る
おばぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ!!　え!?
行くよ?!
行くよ
行くよ　はやくぅww
ああーーーー　落ちなぁい!!　はっはぁww
右手の人差し指に出します　なるほど
そのまま目にブチ込むと　こうっしょ??
うん　俺ホントに入れるよもう　知らないよ俺
え、うわーわわわわわあっわあーーww
うふふふふwww
ほんと怖いからね　行きますよ行きますよ
あぁー　やばい
ふっ、口は開けなくていいんだよ
うわぁ　ふっ
ん、んんー
皮は大丈夫かな　皮はちょっと
入れますよもう　はい
閉じたら意味ないよ
あぁもうあーーーー　この辺をしっかりぐってやっといた
ほうがいいよ
これどう
それひぇひぇひぇwww
閉じちゃった　無ー理ー
はい
閉じようとしないで
閉じちゃダメ
寝ちゃだめぇ
へダムwww　無ー理ー
これ痛くないの
これもうなんか汚いから使えないじゃん
めっちゃ落しちゃったんだけど
うわめっちゃゴミついてるもん、ほら
ホントだもうだめだね　だめだね!!　入れます
まさき頼んだ
イケる
ホント無理じゃない　どうしろっていうのこれ
え、これホント難しいよ　いくぜ
どう?
はっはぁwww　こうなってる
もっと真ん中?　もっとこっちより
上にしっかり入れないと
行きます　はい　どう?
いい感じ
もうやだぁ　なんで?　なんで
こうなっちゃうの　もっと
開けないの?　無理だよ
これ以上開いたら
目とれちゃうよ
ちょ、カメラ見ながら本気でやるわ
む　え
えーー
おしいな
イケそう
だったね
今　うん　まさき
入れてよ　一回
え、やだ怖い
ちょっと一人じゃ
むりなんで
まさきに
入れてもらいます
さあ、来い
えやっふぁww
ポロー
はは
ははん
はは、あ来た
はは!?　来た　は
は?　入ったよ
え?これ俺、目閉じ
ていいの?　うん　閉じた中ぁ
おっ
できた
できた　できた―
やったー!!!!!!!w
え、すごい
一応つけたら、こんな感じの目になりました
かっこいいね
はい、というわけで無事付いたんですけど
痛いのと、めちゃくちゃ
難しいというね
てか、今も痛いんですよ
ほらも涙がとまんないぜ、痛くて
どうやってとるの　待って
取るの難しくない!?　これ　まさきとって
うそでしょ　えやはは
ははぇwwww　あぁーごめん
いいよいいよガッツリいっていいよ
はい、取れた　うわはぁーは
痛ぇーへーww　うーふふーんww
ふふふふーん(泣)
ううう
俺もコンタクト死ぬかと思った
ほんと怖いよ
良かった救急車呼ぶことなくて　危な、ほんと危な
一歩間違えてたら死んでたよ
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑
本日のニュースをお伝えします。
NTTドコモがiモードケータイの出荷終了を発表
NHK受信契約義務、初の意見判断へ
三重県、野菜高騰につき学校給食の中止を決定
押切もえさんとロッテ涌井投手が結婚
以上で本日のニュースを終わります
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓
ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ☆